in this video we're about to break down
the spoilers for mikey academia chapter
337 in which the whole of class when he
discovers that aoyama is the uh traitor
the chapter last week ended with him
confessing to midoriya that he's been
working for all for one and today i'll
be explaining what happens next by the
end of this video you'll understand how
oyama can still be useful to the heroes
and how something in this chapter subtly
confirms that one of the teachers is
also a traitor believe me i'm not
exaggerating when i say that but as the
video goes on you'll see exactly what
i'm talking about before we get into it
though don't forget to sub to the
channel for weekly spoiler breakdowns
like this and drop a like as well if you
like the video
okay so the title of chapter 337 is a
disposable life which is a reference to
how all for one perceives aoyama the
chapter begins on the villain side of
things with darby saying that it'll be
bad for them if the traitor's identity
is discovered by the other students but
afro replies saying it won't be a big
deal to him aliama and his parents are
just disposable tools so if they fail it
doesn't really matter because he can
always move on to the next plan
the scene then switches over to the
forest with yuga's parents grabbing
their son as they start running away
from deku aoyama himself continues to
cry as he remembers the past and thinks
back to how much his parents have always
cared for him since he was a baby he
imagines they must have been even sadder
than he was when it was revealed he was
quirkless which is the only reason they
listened to the rumors about a guy who
could give quirks to other people yuga
remembers that when the power he
received wasn't compatible with his body
his parents did their best to provide
equipment to help him use it and he was
excited to start pursuing his dream
however this is when all for one started
giving them orders as it was him that
told ayama to apply to ua because afo
knew that all might was going to be
joining the school as a teacher
now this line right here literally
confirms that there is more than one ua
traitor besides aoyama and i'm going to
explain why
if we flash all the way back to chapter
11 the news that almighty would be
teaching at ue didn't become public
knowledge until after the kids had
already begun their studies
all might confirm that he didn't tell a
single person he was going to be joining
ua even deku himself didn't know until
after he completed the entrance exam
at this point in the timeline the only
people who might have known that all
might was going to become a teacher were
nezu almighty himself and potentially
said naitai as well but nobody in the
public should have known except them yet
somehow afo was able to tell aoyama
months before the public announcement
the only logical explanation is that
someone on the inside of the school told
him in advance and out of the candidates
we currently have nezu is the only real
option given that all might obviously
wouldn't tell off one himself and naitai
was almost biggest fan so highly
unlikely would have betrayed him let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below but like i said all
mike confirmed he didn't tell anyone
right so if he didn't tell anyone how is
it that all for one knew this before the
public announcement the only explanation
is that nezu told him like he is the
only viable candidate so it only makes
sense for nezu to be the one meaning
there is a second traitor at ua
those of you that haven't seen my nezu
trader theory should really check it out
as i explain things in a lot more detail
there but to simplify it for this video
nezu is a creation of dr garaki and all
for one's experiments the manga heavily
implied that mice were responsible for
the manifestation of quirks and someone
like garaki therefore had a reason to
test on mice when he was researching
about his quirk singularity theory my
theory is that one of those mice was
modified and given a quirk from afo and
then would eventually go on to become
principal nezu who is a character that
is confirmed to have been heavily
experimental in the past
if i had to guess nezu's plan was that
almight would give his power to someone
that he chose himself aka miria or
someone like that and then afo would
ambush that student and steal one full
before they could master it
anyway back to this chapter afo's most
recent order to aoyama was for him to
somehow make midoriya leave you again
otherwise his parents would die
yuga keeps crying as he shoots the laser
directly at deku but her gakurei uses
her power to reflect the laser in a
different direction which is a combo
move they've actually demonstrated in
the past
she asked aoyama how he would have felt
if everyone died when he betrayed them
and as invisible girl cries we actually
start to see some of her face for the
first time i guess this is down to the
way the laser is reflecting although if
this is all it takes i'm genuinely
surprised we've not seen it before today
yuga's parents then turn around and try
to explain their side of the story but
deku easily restrains the entire aoyama
family using black whip izuku says that
they need to stop this once and for all
and that invisible girl's actions in the
last chapter were to stop the aoyamas
from hurting anyone else
things then cut to the classroom where
yugo and his parents are tied to chairs
in front of all my nezu detective
tsukuchi the other teachers and all of
class 1a
they analyzed the situation trying to
estimate when the quote must have been
given to aoyama and they assumed that it
must not have an explosion mechanism
like negan's
those of you who saw my chapter review
last week will know that i think
aoyama's parents are likely to have an
explosion mechanism inside them but
assuming they don't i'm curious how old
for one exactly would kill them the
explosion mechanism is the best way to
do it because they're not safe anywhere
they go but if they don't have that then
you'd think they would have felt safer
being at ua regardless all my asks are
students to leave and we see a panel
showing all of them shocked saying that
they're not leaving odora wonders what
would have happened if a gakurei didn't
find out and kiroshima screams in
disbelief asking aoyama to say it's all
a lie
meanwhile bakugou states that he never
expected to meet another quirkless
person who received a power from someone
else and that the world really must be a
small place detective sukuchi then asks
the aoyamus to reveal everything they
know about afo but the father claims
that they don't know anything and that
they just received the quirk and were
following orders apparently all for one
even showed them dead bodies so they
would understand what would happen if
they lied to him or if aoyama failed in
his mission
yuga then starts saying that because his
classmates were so nice to him he ended
up acting this way to get closer to
everyone even though he knew he might
one day have to kill them however after
reading deku's letter and finding out
that midoriya himself used to be
quirkless aoyama then became depressed
which is something that everyone else
seemed to notice
he ends his speech by declaring himself
to be a villain down to his core and
that even his soul is rotten but deku
replies saying if that was really the
case he wouldn't have tried to save
tokiyami and bakago during the training
camp and he also wouldn't have written
that message in the cheese which was
actually a cry for help izuku goes on to
say that aoyama is only crying now
because he didn't want to betray his
friends which is proof that he isn't
truly all for one side midoriya then
starts talking about his experience with
lady nagant and how even though she had
her heart used by all for one that
didn't stop her in the end from you know
helping the heroes achieve their goal
according to midoriya no one should be
called a villain for the rest of their
lives over a single crime and the
chapter ends with him reaching his hand
out to aoyama telling him that he can
still become a hero
yuga then takes his hand in response and
i can already think of one crazy way
that they can use him being the traitor
to trick all for one
from this chapter we learned that afo
wants midoriya to leave ue again so the
aoyamus could send him a message making
it seem like they've succeeded with deku
then actually leaving the school on his
own we saw in chapter 335 that shigaraki
still has the search quirk so the
villains would be able to verify that
midoriya is by himself and therefore
aliyama's parents would be safe
however what afo wouldn't know is that
deep underground the remaining heroes
and students would be following deku
using the ua barrier which can travel in
multiple directions and wouldn't be
detected by the search quirk straight
away in this way midoriya would seem
like he's alone when in reality the ua
barrier could bring the kids to the
surface at any time to give him backup
this might give the villains a false
sense of security and all four one and
shiguraki would likely confront izuku
only to be confronted by all the
different heroes who were secretly
waiting for them to show up
the only remaining question is would
nezu try to sabotage a plan like this if
it took place and the answer is most
likely yes but hopefully someone would
notice what he's doing but we'll see
what happens
if you like this video then i'd really
appreciate if you smash that sub button
for more content like this and until the
next one peace out
you